Marvel's The Avengers: Age of Ultron is a
guaranteed box office hit, but it's also the
next big junction point in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
That means there are more than a few story
threads and characters that could be introduced
or explored in the film, in order to further
expand the MCU into Phase 3 (and beyond).
Here are 10 Marvel Cinematic Universe Easter
Eggs Fans Want to See in Avengers 2.
10.
Black Panther's World
Marvel has a lot of new heroes coming in the
aftermath of Avengers 2, but in the case of
Black Panther, we don't expect the character
to really appear until Captain America: Civil
War.
However, Black Panther's world and backstory
we fully expect to be referenced in Avengers
2.
In Avengers 2, we know that Andy Serkis will
play Ulysses Klaw, a villain who, in the comics,
steals an iconic metal called Vibranium from
Black Pather's homeland, Wakanda, killing
Black Panther's father in the process.
Based on trailers, Klaw helps Ultron upgrade
his body with Vibranium - but how that goal
is achieved could set into motion events that
eventually bring Black Panther into contact
with The Avengers.
9.
World War Hulk
It's a big expectation that Hulk will be taking
a leave of absence after Avengers 2 - possibly
into space.
That speculation has led to rumors of a "Planet
Hulk" movie, but that Marvel Comics story
about Hulk conquering an alien world has always
been too heavy with CGI and budget demands
to seem viable as a live-action movie.
Even if we never actually see the events of
"Planet Hulk" onscreen, however, the "World
War Hulk" storyline (when Hulk returns to
Earth as a conquering warlord) is something
future movies could explore.
8.
Ant-Man on Deck
In bold departure from Marvel Comics history,
Ant-Man (aka Hank Pym) won't be introduced
into the MCU until after Ultron has been created.
But that doesn't mean that Pym's comic book
connections with the evil robot can't still
be referenced in some way.
Age of Ultron trailers have already shown
flashbacks which bring historical elements
of the MCU to the forefront.
One of those historical events could conceivably
be research done by Hank Pym that helps Tony
Stark create Ultron.
That's all speculation, but needless to say
fans are hoping some trace of the classic
Hank Pym/Ultron origin stays intact.
7.
Agents of Carter
Given the events of the first Avengers film,
there is still one big elephant-in-room within
the MCU: Phil Coulson's resurrection.
Many fans hope that the world-threatening
events of Age of Ultron will at finally force
Coulson to re-unite with the super team he
first inspired to work together.
On the villain side, HYDRA's experiments on
superpowered beings is something that AoS
and AoU will definitely have in common - and
there's also evidence in the trailers that
Peggy Carter will appear in Avengers 2.
It seems clear that Marvel TV will at least
get some kind of reference from its big-budget
cousin.
6.
Strange Magic
Avengers Age of Ultron is also the venue where
we expect to be introduced to yet another
new factor in the MCU (besides superpowers
and cosmic beings): magic.
Based on what we've seen, there are possible
connections between the Scarlet Witch and
Doctor Strange, the big mystic in the Marvel
Universe, who will star in his own 2016 film
played by Benedict Cumberbatch.
The source of Scarlet Witch's psychic/telekinetic
powers in Avengers 2 have been remained mysterious
- especially since the MCU cannot use mutants
in its films due to legal issues with Fox.
Based on images and tie-in merchandise, Scarlet
Witch's powers in the movie seem to have the
same kind of stylized energy signature as
Doctor Strange, meaning Avengers 2 could be
the introduction to a whole realm of MCU magic.
5.
Beginning of the End... of Times
Avengers 2 will find Thor living amongst humanity
full-time as its protector; however, the Asgardian
prince's love of mankind could be sorely tested
by the time Age of Ultron is over is he could
return home only to face a greater threat
to the cosmos: Sultur and the fire demons.
Now that we know Thor: Ragnarok is coming
to theaters, it's clear that while Thor and
the Avengers are battling evil robots on Earth,
events in Asgard are going to be headed toward
the end of days.
4.
Galactic Guardians
Since Guardians of the Galaxy became a hit,
fans have wondered when in where it will connect
to Avengers.
Guardians director James Gunn has openly stated
that, at least for now, the franchise is more
of its own thing, but fans no doubt hope that
Age of Ultron will lay some kind of foundation
for a crossover, so things don't completely
jump the shark when Rocket Raccoon is eventually
trading banter with Tony Stark.
Thanos and the Infinity Gauntlet/Stones are
the most obvious way to connect the two franchises,
so let's discuss THAT possibility...
3.
Beginning of Infinity
Avengers 2 could very well be the film that
begins the process of turning Earth's Mightiest
Heroes into the Universe's Mightiest Heroes
- and the key may be found in Loki's scepter
from the first film.
Marvel has already confirmed that Loki's scepter
IS one of the Infinity Stones, and it's speculated
that in Avengers 2 it is most likely be the
mind gem, which brings Ultron and/or The Vision
to life.
And once the Infinity Stones are once again
in play on Earth, Thanos and his Infinity
War can't be far behind.
2.
Civil Start to War
The events of Age of Ultron (Tony Stark creating
an A.I. that threatens to destroy the world),
is sure going to put a strain on The Avengers
team - one that could conceivably fracture
Steve Rogers and Tony Stark's relationship,
in particular.
In the aftermath of Avengers 2, Rogers and
Stark will likely be standing on opposite
sides of some kind of line, and by the time
Captain America: Civil War arrives, Cap and
his new team of Avengers could be going to
war against Stark and whatever authority he
wields.
For fans watching Avengers 2, the hope is
to see good, weighty dramatic beginnings to
the Cap/Iron Man schism, and perhaps some
final (or post-credits) scene of what Captain
America's new Avengers roster looks like.
1.
Spidey Comes Home
One of the biggest headlines of the last few
years has been Sony finally lending Spider-Man
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Where, when and how Spidey will appear in
the MCU has been subject of debate and speculation
- but needless to say, fans are keeping fingers
crossed that Marvel has worked some kind of
introduction to the character into Avengers
2.
With casting still a mystery, it's doubtful
that Spider-Man will appear in Avengers 2.
But even one strand of his webbing seen during
a post-credit scene would be enough to get
Spidey mania going.
That's it for our list of Easter Eggs fans
are keeping fingers crossed to see in The
Avengers: Age of Ultron!
Let us know in the comments if you have any
other MCU Easter Eggs you hope to see in Avengers
2!
And be sure to subscribe to our YouTube Page!